Oh  rated M for Mature  your grace you're in such a busy little  and mean you're not above using people  to get what you want  good the further north you go the more  likely you'll never come back we head  south you can't stop me from going north  let me guess you're in a very precarious  position a new day is born in Mereen if  it is a fresh scar of basileus pit  fighters knows but till we are artists  to paint in blood that was yesterday  you're all free now we don't know who  you are until you leave  walk with me Roderick it's very  important you see what comes of  disobedience I've done what I needed to  do for family I think we both know it's  a convenient lie we tell ourselves